(rain pattering)
(diners chatting and laughing)
(heartbeat thumping)
- It's hard to take action.
It's painful.
(pensive music)
Washing the dishes isn't fun.
Meditation can be tedious.
Waking up early is hard.
(alarm ringing)
The discomfort we feel
in the face of action
often paralyzes us from
doing anything at all,
so we sleep in.
We get lost in the rabbit hole
of YouTube, TikTok, Instagram,
letting clickbait decide for
us what our next move will be
while our lives slip into disarray.
We resign to inaction
as the solution to avoid
the pain of action,
subconsciously aware of the fact
that our stagnation breeds destruction.
By avoiding the pain of action,
we allow something worse to fester:
the horror of watching
opportunities pass us by.
Our relationships grow distant,
our bills stack up, our families grow old.
Pain is all around us.
It's as much a part of
life as death itself.
No matter how impoverished
or affluent your upbringing,
pain is inescapable.
It'll follow you wherever you go.
And this sobering reality
leads many into nihilism and despair.
But not everyone knows
that there's another
way to look at things.
Pain can be bargained with.
It takes from us, but
it can also give back.
It just depends on which
pain we choose to embrace.
(bright music)
There are two types of pain:
the pain of action and
the pain of inaction.
The pain of action is blunt, in your face,
and forces you to grow.
For every hour we suffer
through sharpening our skills,
being proactive, and restoring order,
we don't reduce the
amount of pain we face,
but rather we take it on the chin,
we sign up for it up front.
And because of this voluntary acceptance,
day after day we gain the
strength to shoulder it.
By embracing pain instead
of running from it,
we are simultaneously transformed by it.
We become someone we are proud of,
someone that others can depend upon,
which in turn gives meaning to the pain.
And it's this feeling
of growth and progress
that helps us feel useful to
ourselves, useful to others,
which gives the suffering a purpose.
(wind whistling)
The pain of inaction, however,
is the pain that eats
away at you, a poison.
(forlorn music)
It's slow-burning,
draining your will and decaying your soul.
By descending into apathy,
things disintegrate. Entropy.
By letting ourselves go, we
lose self-respect. Negligence.
By vegging out on the
couch for days on end,
things fall into disorder.
Inaction is the holiday of fools
who trade temporary discomfort
for long-term existential suffering.
So which pain will we choose?
Action is a life-giving breath;
inaction is a slow death.
Hey, guys.
If you liked the video and you
resonated with the message,
then consider checking out the new merch
that we just redesigned.
We made this new merch line in dedication
of this concept, inaction is a slow death,
which has kind of been the
unofficial-official slogan
of Better Ideas for a long time.
And I really wanted to put
a lot of time and effort
into this video to kind
of send that message.
To really flesh out this whole concept
that inaction is a slow death.
So if you want to rep
Inaction is a Slow Death
on your person, consider
checking out the merch.
It'll only be available
for a limited time,
so as of the time of posting this video
you have three weeks to
get your preorder in.
And you're not obligated to buy the merch
to support the channel.
Your viewership is more than enough.
You know, your likes, your
comments, your engagement,
and just showing up every single video.
It blows my mind how much
support this channel gets.
Thank you guys. Check out
the merch if you want to.
And if you're hurting
for cash, please don't.
But I think it looks cool.
This is your opportunity.
If you are to buy Better Ideas merch,
now is the time 'cause it'll be gone.
So thanks so much, guys. We'll
catch you in the next video.